hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to roblox now roblox is
everybody stop because I just realized I
have to explain the sunglasses I know
that none of you can let the sunglasses
go and I know that you're typing up in
the comments right now what the heck's
with the sunglasses well there's this
weird problem I have with my new office
where I have a window in front of me
which is great because I can see green I
can see a tree I get a little sunlight
and it's really good the problem is in
this room and at this specific time in
the day which is in the afternoon there
is light that shines directly into my
eyes that's reflecting off of my desk
and so I could try to like put up
curtains or something like that but then
it would defeat the purpose of having a
window in the first place so I are these
sunglasses from a me to be perfectly
honest these aren't mine but if they
were you know it wouldn't be too much of
a surprise that's why the sunglasses are
there can we let it go can we get back
to the game now can we get back to the
reason why we're here which is not the
sunglasses stop talking about it
I know I look amazing that's not the
point
of my videos I am aware I am handsomer
than sin I'm aware I'm a beautiful human
being but you all need to let that go
you need to get away from that because
yes I get it it's a burden for me to
look this good but I have to endure this
life and you have to endure this video
so just let bygones be bygones and let's
play some goddamn roblox thank you
anyway so roblox is I don't really know
I haven't actually played roblox before
in fact I haven't played it because I
really don't understand what roblox is
about it as an entity is weird
especially considering there's this
group right here called the German
Empire with what looks to be a Nazi
soldier because the 1940s a majority of
those years were filled with Nazis and I
feel like maybe maybe it's not such a
good idea to use that or I could use
code chest so I installed the client
I tested it out I got it to work and
what I'm gonna do is I've tried a few of
these I want to start you with something
that I actually opened up and I did just
roll
okay let me explain what roblox is from
my general understanding roblox is more
a platform than a game by itself because
you can have basically whatever game you
want in it oh is that an SCP okay so
roblox allows you to make games inside
of roblox which means that people can
make games like a multiplayer SCP game
because the majority of these games in
roblox are multiplayer which is a really
cool concept when you think about it so
yeah like someone just made an SCP game
in here oh okay I died ah here I am okay
good
time left ten seconds okay so what
happens when 10 seconds comes up I'm
assuming that the game is gonna start at
10 seconds I'm not 100% sure how the
game works but I do know that SCP is a
dangerous world to be in I don't know
what to expect
oh my god what is wrong with your face
ahahaha people shooting down there okay
oh I'm a class-d that's not good
avoid SCP and SCP foundation chaos
insurgents can help you oh oh oh oh
gimme gimme gimme gimme yeah I got a
keycard oh you suck I got a keycard
oh god are there like actually scps
around here oh [ __ ] that didn't work
okay I'm in the wrong area hey everybody
wait for me I I would like oh no no no
I'm stuck oh wow guys I got a key I got
the keycard and I went in here I would
like to not die not not dying would be
good I don't know am I supposed to press
another button and my supposed to
actually figure out how to scan this
thing oh god I could open it at any time
I just I had the thing in my hand so I
oh this is now where I want to be this
is what you want this is oh [ __ ] alright
well that's another key card but I don't
need another key card I am just in the
wrong place I am so far behind my fellow
fellows I'm sorry
unless someone can take mercy on my soul
and he'll pay oh no oh no oh oh I don't
want to be here that's now where you
want to be that's not what you want to
see definitely not what you want to see
okay
all right wait that was the Tesla gate I
didn't know that this is a keycard door
isn't it
tonight how do i what what what happened
so there's a long time left in that one
so I'm gonna leave that game I didn't do
much and I don't know how I died but
that was kind of cool okay
adopt me mansion I don't know what this
is I'm not on however since a brand new
mansion money trees are back baby adopt
a baby well I I am a bit of a baby oh
look at me welcome to adopt me sir
dressing fashionably of course what
would you like to see clothes for guys
or girls guys please can I find
something stylish put on baby outfit oh
I'm dead oh there are looks like me
where this sunglasses could I put
sunglasses on this bad baby wow there's
a lot of sunglasses what the hell I mean
the problem is none of them are like
opaque but that'll do that'll do okay so
we got we got me here
all right saved ah mark a baby okay cool
how do I get out of here
all right well you look incredible
thanks I know okay here we go oh wow I
went to heaven
ready adoptive coffee let's go the
nursery I didn't say yes hello would you
like to adopt me
I'm a baby I'm a baby why somebody adopt
me a tiny motorcycle is that a baby
sighs oh please dance dance one Wow
now that is a dance dance too oh boy wow
that dance three Oh
Wow I'm not a hundred percent sure but I
just realize I'm a very fast run me over
Ali do you want to adopt me I'm a baby
welcome to the nursery where you adopt
pets and family Oh baby
here this is my spot this is me over
here hey I'm a baby I'm just gonna jump
in one of these grips here all right
cool
hey hey hey hey do you know Zara let's
see go oh boy
I'm ready hey mom what how do I talk
with you hi guy I have to leave
that was madness unlike anything you
could see the Sun change Jay dramatic
shift of tone you can see the Sun here
shining on me light cast from the center
of MA from the center of the Sun right
into mine
so that was the thing I did that I feel
real weird weightlifting simulator oh
hell yeah oh hell yeah give me the big
muscle
oh oh oh my god is that a Titan I'm so
skinny oh my god holy crap Oh
oh my god Jennifer okay stats I got
nothing I got no buffness no height how
do I get height I don't know man I don't
know this is really funny
okay can I lift something ah okay I'm
gonna be so freakin fast okay okay
that's that's F of that oh my god oh my
god oh my god
weight will lift oh yeah oh there we go
I love it I love it it's true yeah yeah
yeah that's how I do that's how I do
yeah that's all right oh my god this
might be the greatest thing I've ever
seen in my life yeah let's do the brawl
I don't know how I'll get you here it
comes
I I'll get you man I'm coming for you
yeah yeah yeah yeah I guess I should
spend my time lifting okay this is how I
am when I'm at the gym when I'm curling
stone as they call it when I'm Hawking
rock when I'm slinging iron oh come here
you [ __ ] oh yeah oh I'm coming for you
oh yeah you can't handle no no Darius oh
you got your ass kicked
come here you oh [ __ ]
all right cool that didn't do anything
for me hey did my taller am i taller
fine dude this was all it took
I would've never known oh you wanna
fight oh just do that I'll come and get
you
oil you'll come mystified hey yeah hey
yeah hey yeah hey yeah hey yeah imma get
you oh yeah ah that's what you get
yeah you better run pumping up no yeah
you think you think but you're wrong
what y'all smack that ass yeah you
better run away oh yeah oh yeah you're
coming in from
ZZZ oh yeah get go get some of that oh
yeah yeah you better run oh yeah oh yeah
get up on your head you ain't never
gonna get none there's Oh out frick
alright okay alright well this is this
might be my favorite game ever I might
have found the game that I'm just gonna
play for ever
I guess that's what's cool about roblox
is that you can just do whatever the
hell you want don't even think about it
I'm just getting so huge oh I'm getting
huge oh I'm getting huge all these guys
are big but they ain't they ain't fast
so I'm gonna go for speed over
everything
the trick is always getting in one rep
everywhere you go alright so I'm just
gonna run on this for a bit I don't know
why I want to progress in this game
I really don't but there's something
just very compelling about it I don't
know everyone shut up I don't need to
justify why I'm playing this game how
fast am I now
oh not much faster it would take a long
time to get your speed up like a long
time let me just try to get my strength
up for a while
wow that's too big all right let's see
how fair in the brawl now I'm coming for
you gonna get you some of this yeah yeah
get spray I'm gonna get one I'm gonna
get one give me one oh yeah wait wait
hey I got third I was gonna get a kill
but okay I'm tall wait um what did I get
so tall hey I'm pretty dull alright okay
okay anyway I'm gonna get out of this
game before it gets to my head yes
pretty good yeah I like I like I like
that that's just cool um this is a tower
defense simulator game the reason I got
is because it's got this area 51 event
and I wanna I'm going for it no I don't
want to play this one can I leave I'm
gonna leave this one okay inventory okay
Oh interesting
ah okay alright so I got two things do I
put them oh okay cool cool cool cool
infernal abyss oh [ __ ] you're going with
one
robloxia sure yeah let's do it yeah
let's come on let's do it
come on come on it was the brain come on
get market brain I don't know what
difficulty we want no easy easy easy
mode easy I like easy
I want easy I love tower defense games I
really do
I haven't played some in a long time but
I used to play them all the time like in
Starcraft 2 custom games and stuff like
that I can upgrade them ok so that's
good I I guess I didn't need this much
range it's a lot more range than I
thought I would need I mean this seems
pretty easy I'm not gonna lie this is
not exactly what I would call difficult
at the moment we can we cheat this ahead
a little faster it is pretty slow but
then most of these tower defense games
they start off slow and then they get
really tough really quickly I like I
like mr. cowboy here a kaboom oh wow
you're so buff have you been on lifting
Beach can we just go ahead and skip like
launch them all because this is like
real Snoozeville oh yeah that's what I'm
talking about I'm gonna make him like
strong just boss killers that's what
they're gonna be their only job is to
kill the bosses no matter what can we
squeeze another on this ledge here nah
well higher up we go then yeah get em
kick their ass I've never considered
roblox for anything of ever in my life
but now that I'm seeing what it actually
is this is surprisingly not bad pretty
cool yeah
oh you're saving I'm saving the day one
more on this oh yeah here's my squad of
five my course of snipers here fun
that's fun also what a ripoff of Lego
what a what a what a complete nutter
ripoff of Lego you know I gotta say it
it is this is straight-up Lego do not
tell me that
what's encoding overload is that better
I got a killer squad here of brutal
murderers thank going anywhere
oh this is this is just pure
annihilation this this is nothing
there's there's no hope left okay so
like I said I have no idea if the video
quality was just absolute garbage
beforehand
I don't know why because what that means
is roblox is such an intense powerful
game that it requires only the strongest
of computers to be able to possibly keep
up with this amazing amazingly
incredibly powerful game that's what
that's saying to me
okay well hang on wait there they're
going through but good thing my guys
have such range don't worry my guys will
eventually take care of them eventually
I want to talk to those guys want to
take care of that guy but whoa boy wait
a minute hang on wait wait this seems to
be a bit of a problem here
maybe I just put one of these here and
was here and lazy here [ __ ] hidden I
forgot about well who died I tried well
look man look what for me I you didn't
do anything what were you doing don't
play time music for me I was doing fine
it was their fault for accelerating the
levels I knew they should know better
that's not my fault
that's not my fault I'll just go here
you know I'm just gonna play winter and
if anyone joins me they join me if they
don't they don't it's all good hey
alright never mind
I need no friends I just me myself and I
all by myself
they see the guy just staring lonely
into the wall no one wants to be my
friend and helped me here I go goodbye
everybody
it's probably fine that I'm by myself
probably definitely fine oh yay okay
well I'm gonna go with easy go with
really easy on this one which way is the
front which way is the back okay good
okay I'm gonna put my guys right right
there that seems smart real smart there
we go yeah buddy
I need money can I have money I've got
no money oh oh this would be fine that's
perfect for this guy oh sorry I'm gonna
put two these bad boys right up squeezed
against each other now nothing's gonna
get by
I feel like things are gonna get by at
some point easy like it's nothing like a
dream oh it's fine
it's it's definitely fun let's hold off
on the next wave let's uh let's make
sure that we can get through this one
first cuz that is still up in the cards
up in the clouds it's up in the sky the
sky clouds it's up in the cloud skies
sky of clouds get a cloud sky sky clouds
yeah we're good
this is gonna get super dicey at some
point er yeah bring it on yeah bring on
the next bring on all of bring on the
waves just wave me up it's okay my body
can take it my body can handle this my
body can withstand this of [ __ ] boss
incoming yeah bring on the next wave
yeah let's keep going yeah let's roll
let's roll baby come on oh this is
nothing
oh I've got this in the bag never mind
maybe I don't maybe maybe I don't maybe
I do maybe I do I might I might Am I oh
yeah I do okay that's a bit of a problem
yeah bring the waves yeah you're doing
pretty good now I need to get to the
point where I'm upgrading the next
levels on these bad boys what oh [ __ ]
I'm alive and perfectly well what well
that makes no sense alright sure yeah
okay
what's up grade baby with the upgrades
going oh yeah oh yeah they're making is
surprisingly easy on me I'm assuming
that the guy in the last game who was
like I'm saving money just was being an
idiot and didn't want to spend their
money for some reason and therefore left
me to bake up the mess and that's why we
seemed to be doing so much better now
and yet before we were nearly due
that's what I'm suspecting has happened
okay I could do this all day I could do
this all day
but I won't because that's not what this
is about this is about exploring roblox
not getting stuck on a tower defense
game it's not why I'm here it's not why
I'm here
just in case the footage in the other
games was for some reason roblox out I'm
gonna see about this one which is called
parkour so sonic some term not Sonic
okay I'm just gonna be sonic okay cool
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm sorry I'm very sorry I'm very sorry
I'm very sorry okay ah
parkour indeed I love parkour yeah oh my
god oh my god oh my god that's this is
roblox alright there's a hundred percent
of roblox I think we all understand this
okay here I go
what are we doing am I supposed to touch
these er oh well I guess I wasn't
supposed to touch them then a book well
it wasn't very clear that's it alright I
guess I'm not supposed to touch those
okay cool good yeah Boing Boing Boing
Boing great did it love it I guess okay
good good can I go up oh oh I see I
don't see okay save so far so not so bad
don't know why I'm going on the pokey
balls of doom
nailed it I'm the best Oh what I'm sorry
I'm sorry wait yeah wait hey I'm sorry
I'm I apologize I'm sorry
rope I don't want to buy roblox can
people make money from this is that what
I'm starting to understand is that like
people that make these games they can
they can actually earn money from this
crap is that what I'm discovering is
that people who make these games if they
get people to spend roebucks
in their games that's horrible that's
wrong they can make money from this
because that's awesome and something
that I had no I
it was even a you know ah maybe
may-maybe oh [ __ ] uh skip let's skip
it
alright cool I skipped it whoo good
great got it alright here we go boy and
point and point and boy and a little
patience goes a long way yeah there we
go he's peasy lemon squeeze me okay good
I I'm not a hundred percent sure okay
okay great it's good stuff okay good
stuff okay good stuff alright good stuff
whoa
good stuff get out of my way get out of
my way I'm on a race here I'm going for
gold baby maybe I am going for gold
alright cool good it seemed to be doing
pretty okay okay good good Oh Beast Boy
beast man boy Dunham's ah ah ah you suck
so much ninja warrior up in here why am
I doing this why am i why am i doing
this I have no idea why I'm doing this
I don't know where am I going what does
happen hi spongebob hi was this supposed
to be a trick or something I don't know
I have no idea all right okay oh I see I
don't know why now it's suddenly saving
me where I go cuz I swear I've stepped
over these before and it did not do thus
the things such as the like as oh it's a
trick it was a trap why am I doing this
I have no idea why I'm doing this but I
want to get to the end I don't know why
but I do want to get to the end I can
[Music]
you do the rest of the game like that
cuz I was I was nice that was a nice
boost slide down with the box
oh that's pretty cool I like that that's
fun this games fun ah eat my ass no a
maze oh no yeah yeah I made it out okay
good great I guess I could have skipped
that but whatever all right what do i
what do I wait what do i oh yeah nice
what is the point of this am I giving
close to the end I really don't know but
I've made a lot of progress I don't know
if I should be proud of that or if she I
should be really disappointed in myself
that I've actually kept going like this
because I don't know it just feels bad
it feels real bad I made it to 44 but it
seems like people are stuck on 61 so I'm
thinking sixty one's got to be the end I
don't know I could use my coins I guess
but it won't be the point of that I
wouldn't have the thrill of the victory
and I wouldn't be able to go on this
plane okay all right Air Force one right
got it nailed it oh I see my supposed to
ah okay here we go
I don't know how to use it whew Oh
[Laughter]
interesting
oh my god oh my god okay alright cool
this is messed up man this is very
messed up imma ignore the fact that is
incredibly messed up oh god it continues
all with the doge is bore Fionn into the
the river here it's very nice the
aesthetic is just breathtaking and the
silence is just weird but good thing
lick sea and put in music this all-time
or otherwise this would be a very dull
and droll thing something something good
to listen to for long periods of time as
absolutely nothing Oh skip
hey Manny good for me all right let's do
this parkour here we go all right what
is this guessing game hate it skip it
love it got it nailed it skipped it okay
Oh
roblox I think I'm getting close to the
end in fact I think that's the end dead
ahead unless I'm mistaken which I might
because I'm stupid
oh right a skip okay cool good hey I did
it
whoa whoa whoa excuse me oh that's a
good speed okay good great Oh aah Oh
kingdom of the Crystal Skull II I like
this one wait my crown please not that
this please no not that this please no
not that nerve now that this no this
that this all of it put it all on my
head
oh there we go aha oh [ __ ]
not that one god damn it god damn it I
had it and I lost it I had it and lost
it and it's gone
there we go no oh my god I swear there
we go don't yes there we go ok good
swings wrong oh I can't seem to build up
a lot of momentum here I'm trying my
best real hard to get momentum going ok
but good yeah I did it guys hey all that
huh okay all right cool I'm done okay
that was so fun so fun glad I did that
anyway hope the rest of the footage
wasn't garbage and that's roblox I don't
know if I'm gonna go back to it maybe
I'll go back to the weightlifting one
but yeah I think I'd rather just play
like the horror stuff than the cutesy
stuff but there's a lot here and you
know you can't really fault it for that
it's like free games you
can play whatever you want you can make
some games if you wanna get to that and
then yeah you know it's pretty is pretty
ok it's pretty ok so thank you everybody
so much for watching if you want to play
roblox for yourself
good luck I'll I'm not even gonna put it
in the description because go find it on
your own cuz you're gonna need to look
up a guide because it's pretty hard to
get started so thank you again everybody
so much for watching I'll put in the
description thank you and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]